father why do I still feel guilty the
counter means your work is not yet
finished
downtown office thinks we got new
players in Hell's Kitchen what they want
DS and offices to shoot is independent
he's tracking gangs to their home turf
and taking them out with military
precision knowledge and hardware to take
out half the city Hell's Kitchen is
about to explode
we've recreated him
all of us there's no connection we never
stop to think that Daredevils actions
could open the door for men like this
much longer before innocent people start
getting caught as crossfire
blood is being shed you donated more
than your fair share
the city needs help
I need to take care of the scum that
killed my family people don't have to
die you hit them and they get back up I
hit him and they stay down why are you
doing this cuz I think you're a
half-measure I think you're a man who
can't finish the job I think you're a
coward
you know you're one bad day away from me
Elektra hello
hey youtubers it's Charlie so they just
dropped the daredevil season 2 official
trailer we get our first look at Frank
Castle there's a new player in town so
let's break it down I'd be really
surprised if none of you have ever heard
of The Punisher before what they've done
because the Punisher is a relatively old
character he's a war vet whose family is
brutally murdered so it drives him to
seek justice in the most extreme way
possible he kills the bad guys that he
goes after instead of daredevil on the
other side of this equation who doesn't
want to kill that was a big thing during
season 1 when he first ran into night
nurse and he threw the guy over the
building and he's still building he
landed in that dumpster that I was in
earlier just like last season there's a
lot of comic book things going on but
they're not necessarily doing an exact
copy of a comic book storyline daredevil
and Punisher have a long history of
working together and fighting each other
in the comics so think of daredevil
season 2 as a couple different things
one the rise of the Punisher it'll be
like an origin story for the Punisher in
daredevil vs Punisher and then also
daredevil vs. Elektra because Elektra is
actually the old college girlfriend that
foggy was talking about during season 1
which is also fairly true to the comics
but if you remember season 1 mimicked a
lot of Man Without Fear things from that
Frank Miller storyline that's the story
that introduced the Elektra character so
it's almost like they've removed her
from season 1 and inserted her into
season 2 just to keep things simpler
which I'm totally fine with they needed
to spend most of season 1 explaining why
daredevil becomes daredevil his main
villain the kingpin now that they've
done that they can broaden the universe
with people like the Punisher and
Elektra but like I said even if the
first part of the season is gonna be
daredevil versus Punisher
they'll probably reach some sort of
agreement Punisher will still be crazy
no matter what he's still gonna try and
kill bad guys so I'm wondering where
they're gonna leave the season what
common ground they'll find because
daredevil is never gonna think it's okay
to kill a bad guy maybe he'll just kill
fewer bad guys like it seems like the
body count is gonna be super high in the
first couple of episodes there's a new
player military precision
that's just meant to honor his history
in the Special Forces as in before he
became the Punisher he was already a
badass at killing people now I just love
the way this trailer plays with that
nursery rhyme it shows you the Frank
Castle origin story we have his home
here we have a flashlight looking at
this children's book a picture of him
with his daughter and him at the park
sitting at this merry-go-round
in the comics his family was
brutally murdered in a mob shootout they
might do that the same here because the
kingpin and a lot of his associates are
deeply connected to the mob but I'm
interested to see how they weave out the
origin story
they might flashback to his time as a
Marine and I think because they've
updated the series this is happening in
modern day he'll be in Afghanistan that
daredevil sees that someone's killing
mobsters so he wants to know what
they're out for but the twist is
Punisher doesn't want anything he just
wants to make bad guys pay in the most
severe way possible which is a really
dangerous thing you can bargain with
someone who wants a physical thing like
I'm trying to take X object from you you
can always bargain with people like that
but when someone wants to hurt people
there's not a lot that you can give them
that will save that desire there's no
satisfaction that you can give them now
the first time Punisher appeared it was
in a spider-man story don't think that's
gonna be happening anytime soon on the
Netflix series because of Marvel's
arrangement with Sony there might be
some references to spider-man I know you
guys have been asking me a lot of Civil
War questions for Captain America Civil
War
Punisher had a lot of fun during that
comic book storyline so if you want to
read a Punisher run that will also get
you ready for Civil War you can read mat
fractions run on Punisher War Journal
its vol 2 and it takes place during
Civil War if you really want a deep cut
Jim Lee inked the first run of Punisher
War Journal so you can go back and read
vol 1 2 the difference between Punisher
Punisher War Journal and Punisher max
are just varying degrees of WTF so I
would say Punisher War Journal is a
really solid bet but you also need to
read daredevil vs Punisher just read
that storyline I love that he calls
daredevil a coward you're a half-measure
you're just one bad day away from being
me and doesn't it look by the way
they're holding each other in the rain
here the Karen page finally figures out
that Matt is daredevil you're the guy
that saved me that day in the rain I
know she has that line where she's like
maybe we created him maybe us being so
hardcore inspired other people to go
even further that's only half true but
that doesn't mean that daredevil was
responsible for what Punisher does so
it's not like the Punisher has lost his
mind he sees a course of action and is
going about it in the most logical way
he knows how
gangsters are a problem the system is
broken
we now come down they keep getting back
up so I have to knock them down so that
they don't get back up again electro is
a bit of a question mark she's an
assassin for hire so I'm wondering if
the gangsters that Punisher goes after
hire her to take the Punisher down
kingpin still a big player not to be
forgotten even though he doesn't appear
in this trailer I'm wondering if he's
still gonna be in prison but he'll still
be calling the shots influencing things
from inside that cell the matically it
feeds into what Punisher is talking
about
just because daredevil knocked King ping
down a peg put him in prison doesn't
mean that he hasn't gotten back up since
then whatever the case is I do feel like
Elektra is going to be hired by one of
the villains to take down either
Punisher or daredevil maybe both of them
I don't know if they're gonna wind up
being friends by the end or if they'll
wind up being enemies
maybe there's this inverse relationship
with daredevil and Punisher daredevil
and Punisher start out as enemies
probably going to be less enemies I
wouldn't say friends but they won't be
fighting each other by the end of the
series maybe it'll be the opposite for
daredevil and Elektra but they've worked
together for so long in the comics I
feel like they're not gonna be enemies
at the end they'll probably just find
some common ground just like daredevil
and Punisher it's not like everyone's
gonna be hugging each other at the end
of the series they'll just be like okay
we're not gonna try and shoot each other
in the face the next time we see each
other but I know a lot of you guys have
been asking about the Punisher series
that they've greenlit I have no idea
when it's gonna drop but they are gonna
be making a TV series that's more
focused on the Punisher he will be part
of defenders no I have no idea which
movie he's gonna wind up in the
defenders are supposed to show up during
infinity war either part 1 or part 2 I
don't I don't know which one but yes I
do believe that Punisher would come
along for the ride they're supposed to
be 66 characters in infinity war so
they're gonna be bringing their a-game
and Punisher looks like he's gonna be
freaking awesome
you don't want him to ride the bench
during infinity war and how awesome is
it that they told us when the next
trailer is coming how many people do
that usually studios just dump it in the
morning on a random day like a Monday or
a Tuesday like oh hey by the way here's
this giant trailer so at the end of the
month the next trailer will probably
reveal more about what the actual story
is going to be I'm not expecting to see
kingpin and I'm not expecting to see the
punisher costume that'll probably like
the daredevil reveal in season 1 where
he starts out in the black costume then
he gets the red costume at the end so by
the end of season 2 that's when I think
the Frank castle will be wearing the
skull t-shirt let me know what's your
favorite thing about this and all the
episodes are gonna drop on March 18th
that'll be a Friday night it's just like
last season it'll precede Captain
America silver
and is dropping the week before Batman V
Superman comes out in related news there
has been a whole bunch of Deadpool Game
of Thrones Walking Dead stuff going on
I'm doing a game of Thrones Q&A that
I'll post next just in case you guys
haven't seen it I've done a whole bunch
of daredevil season 2 videos you can
click here for that big playlist and you
can click here for the Game of Thrones
trailer that I did last night thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you